[موسيقى]
هو أشبه بمشاهدة فيلم غامر
ووجود شخص ما يقدم
لك طعامًا ذواقة في نفس الوقت
[موسيقى]
قصة غامضة وتناول طعام راقٍ من دبي ربما يكون
ذروة
تناول الطعام الفاخر ، لكن مأدبة
هوشينا ترفع من مستوى هذا الأمر بالتأكيد
ثلاث مرات في المرة الأولى التي
جئت فيها لم يكن لدي أي فكرة عما يمكن توقعه
[موسيقى]
كنت جالسًا واستقبلني أحد النادل ،
كانت الأضواء بالطبع خافتة
جدًا ثم رأيت تمثالًا يبدأ في
التحدث
على هذا الضيف ، الرجاء المساعدة
لن أتخلى عن القصة بأنفسكم ، لكن
مع تقدمكم في
الدورات الخمس ، تطور القصة
[موسيقى] ،
فإن الإبداع الذي يتخلف وراء كل
وجبة يتم تسليمها إلى المائدة
يكون رائعًا للغاية مدروس جيدًا
هناك بضع لحظات  في
العرض حيث يتعين عليك التفاعل ،
هناك جزء حيث يتعين عليك وضع
يدك على الطاولة ، حيث
يتدفق تيار كهربائي من خلاله ، مما
يجعلك تشعر تقريبًا أن
الطعام شهي ، خاصةً
الحلوى [الموسيقية] التي تنظر إليها  في ذلك ، وتعتقد
أنه لم يعد لديك مكان آخر ، ولكن
بعد ذلك يكون لذيذًا ، وربما تتوقع أن
تؤمن قليلاً بالسحر في نهايته
[موسيقى]